no you are just a murderer in this
notebook is the deadliest weapon of mass
murder in the history of mankind
you yielded to the power of the
Shinigami and the notebook and you have
confused yourself with a God in the end
you are nothing more than a crazy serial
killer that's all you are nothing more
and nothing less hello and welcome to
Death Note 101 series it breaks down
everyone and everything in the Death
Note world and today we are going to be
taking a look at another socially
awkward detective trial genius by the
name of Nia Nia also known as neat River
is an extraordinarily intelligent boy
with hunched-over posture white shaggy
hair and a tendency to dress in all
white clothing he is the younger of the
two offensive wammy's house who were
chosen as successes to the legendary
detective l following his death at the
hands of kira near love solving puzzles
so much so that they seem to inform his
greater view on life as he often thinks
that even crimes are simply a game or
challenge that must be won by any means
necessary as a young boy near was taken
to the orphanage miami's house which was
founded by climbing a k' Watari in order
to gather genius-level children to
potentially act as the successor for l
in the case of his death and during his
time at the orphanage near studied
incredibly hard and apparently proved
himself to be one of the most
intelligent children in the entire
Institute as a result when L did
eventually die Nia and another child
named Mello were brought into the office
of Roger OVA the manager of wammy's
house in order to be told the news of
his death
NIR reacted rather calmly and
apathetically towards this information
simply stating that if you cannot solve
the puzzle than you are a mere loser
and even though L hadn't had the chance
named either near or Mello as his
official successor Mello took it upon
himself to decide that Nia was to become
the next L as he was the more
level-headed and admittedly more
intelligent candidate of the two while
smell a result to go on and try and
solve the Kira case in his own way
however it should be noticed that Nia
was more than willing to work together
with Miller on the case showing a level
of maturity far beyond what you'd expect
of your average thirteen-year-old genius
and at this time we should also point
out that the series protagonists don't
cure himself Light Yagami
had commandeered the role of L and was
continuing to mislead investigators with
the help of the remaining members of the
cure task force and when I say helping
them I mean he was tricking them into
doing what he wanted them to do Nia then
spent four years gathering evidence and
information concerning the case and
finally with the help of
the FBI the CIA and even the President
of the United States he created an
organization known as the special
provision for Kyra or spk for short and
this group was tasked with pursuing Kyra
without the current l's help however
after a couple of conversations would
light Nia quickly started to suspect
that he was in fact Kira and started
looking for evidence to prove his
suspicions as part of the confrontations
between the and light the audience was
able to see Nia's capabilities as a
detective firsthand and it should be
noted that he is outrageously smart and
according to the Encyclopedia death no
13 how to read his mental capacities
could even possibly surpass that of L's
although the writer of Death Note
Tsugumi Oba has explicitly stated that L
is the smartest character introduced in
the series so take that information as
you will furthermore as stated before
Nia is capable of absurdly fast puzzle
solving and a very special brand of
outside of the box thinking he has a
very calm personality and actually
enjoys having people around him because
it is said that Nia's mental abilities
work at their highest potential if he
has people around that he is able to
share ideas with kind of like a dr.
house effect in addition to this Nia
also enjoys playing with different kinds
of toys such as finger puppets which he
often uses to represent his allies and
enemies whilst planning his next move in
addition to toys Nia also quite enjoys
dice and has been seen building
miniature castles with them whilst deep
in thought and despite the fact that he
is often depicted as a cold and
calculative individual Nia does actually
deeply care for his co-workers and
childhood friends and to illustrate this
in the manga he is deeply upset when
mello kills members of the SPK in order
to slow down their investigations but
then he later shows great respect
towards Miller when he sacrifices
himself in order for Nia and the sbk to
obtain evidence against sleight now
speaking of a protagonist Nia actually
does not consider lights intelligence to
be anything special whatsoever which is
in stark contrast to Elle who thought of
light as a rival and equal however near
thinks of him only as a mere crazed
serial killer who must be stopped
although in this effort near would face
multiple setbacks during his
investigation such as the President of
the United States declaring that the SPK
is no longer an official government
organization the aforementioned killing
of SP Ches workers by Mello and to the
discovery that there were actually
multiple people using Kira's power in
order to mask the real Kira however in
each and every situation near would end
up rising to the challenge presented and
in the end he did manage to prove with
the help of Miller that Light Yagami was
in fact Kira as well as the fact that
Mikami Teru
was the ex cura although
they could get arrested Mikami terror
committed suicide and light was killed
by the Shinigami Ryoka who wrote his
name in a Death Note following the
closure of the Kira case near officially
took on the title of the world's most
renowned detective and became the third
L fast forward three years and NIR was
now working as ell solving cases in a
similar way to that of his predecessor
and furthermore he is shown to have
matured quite a bit and now possesses an
awful lot of respect towards the
original L even growing to someone
idolized him this is evident in a bonus
chapter at the end of the series where
it is discovered that a new Death Note
has entered the world and someone is
using it to kill elderly people here is
shown pondering what the original L
would have done in this situation and
eventually NIR decides not to
investigate these murders and settles
for sending a video message to the world
in which he states that these murders
weren't committed by the real Kira and
that this killer is merely an abominable
murderer and said abominable murderer
committed suicide shortly after seeing
the video message and as for Nia
as far as we know he is currently
continuing his job as the world's
greatest detective some more fun facts
about Nia although not shown in the
anime Nia is seen eating chocolate at
the very end of the manga most likely as
a sign of respect towards Miller as that
was his trademark habit
fascinatingly enough Nia and Mellors
names were originally planned to be the
other way around
however sometime during the making of
the manga the names were accidentally
mixed up and the author thought that
this was actually a good idea so he
decided to keep the change
Nia's real name Nate river is a
combination of two words natural and
River with the symbolism in Nia's name
referring to the idea that intelligence
flows naturally to him like a river and
finally a truly useless fact other than
the chocolate he ate at the end of the
manga Nia has never been shown eating or
drinking anything but that pretty much
does it for Nia if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produced in general then please do
consider donating to the New World
review patreon it gets the support of
all the amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps plot
this channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
area takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with who what
or where you'd like to see featured in
the next death note 101
[Music]